et la russie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean
seri jean lui jean-luc il s'est passé
quelque chose et un instant et vous n'y
a pas la piste là qu'il faisait beau ici
on va pas vous montrer les images qu'on
va à l'elysée pour aujourd'hui
allez s'il est normal et c'est pourquoi
je sens que tout le monde attendait de
revoir expliquait je vais expliquer le
contexte mais j'en doute parce que
expliquera bien le contexte l'absolu
rochette dans les quartiers en fait
presque en fait je vous êtes en train de
danser au moment jeudi à matthieu
delormeau viens danser aussi hélas
est-ce qu'on va les images où il fait le
beau tout ça et après la le le délire on
l'a ou pas avec le son est tout aussi
bon plan vigie pour d'autres
téléspectateurs
en résumé m oui on en a mais remercie
[Applaudissements]
besson
c'est pas comme si il va doubler de
volume qu'est-ce qu'il arrive une fois
qu'à une chose qui double de volume chez
vous c'est du vol
par devoir jeu merci à vous d'être aussi
nombreux à nous on rigole tellement ces
missions se régale tellement merci à
vous il ya encore près d'un million cinq
cent mille personnes qui ont regardé
touche pas à mon poste et qu'on regarde
et vos chiffres pour vous dire que les
gens sont quand même alors premier
chypre de thierry moreau a les 250 250
les 250 buts que vous avez pris dans une
émission hier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors hier 250 ben oui on a mal compris
vous avez vraiment l'esprit balle soit
celle qui met sa féconde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les 250 bus c'est l'argent non est ce
que c'est un le nombre d'épisodes de
quelque chose non est ce que c'est le
nombre de numéros de fautes des
démissions achetés vendus
est-ce que ça nombre de personnes non
non une audience par michel d'aliments
près des gens lucas y viendra faire un
avis bon oui oui abalessa du coup sa
valise le poids des deux coups donnés à
fond dans bienvenue chez toi t'as vu ça
n'était pas quelque chose à la venue au
zoo une saison au chômage passent sous
le contrôle et zabelle 4 à 8,5 m
oui c'est l'éléphant rentrée alors
annoncé un petit éléphant 256 go alors
un petit éléphant c'est la théière